so I don't think this would work so let
me start with that but there's something
interesting here we're so Netflix
recently left folks in the last few
years started going heavy into comedy
so comedy used to be like HBO kind of
owned the space where they would do you
know HBO specials and then that kind of
dried up and comics are like cockroaches
they'll always survive it's like okay
we'll go play in the dingy estroux meeee
we'll go onstage we'll get it Netflix
special we'll get HBO special okay we're
back to the dark room again like they
won't quit cuz they're like degenerates
and now podcasting has been a huge boom
for them so Chris D'Elia who also just
had a Netflix special come out these
guys make tons of money right so Netflix
started cutting like 10 20 million
dollar checks I believe to these
comedians because they know that
comedians have these like rabid
followings and the content is good it's
unique sort of proprietary content but I
think that there's a product out there
sort of like a crunchy what crunchyroll
did for anime I think somebody could do
for the mid-tier comedians I think you
can make a sort of $5 a month $7 a month
subscription to the comedians that are
not going to get met flick specials
right so not Chris Rock and not Seinfeld
and Chappelle and and all those guys but
like the next tear down like even you
know one level below like the Whitney
Cummings of the world right because they
are still getting Netflix specials and I
think you could add them up and it
doesn't want to be the hour-long special
it could be like a 10-minute set set or
a 20-minute set or something like that
and I think you could get I think each
of them have a few thousand fans that
would pay to be able to access that
exclusive comedy content and and so you
would act if you just aggregate all the
comedians then it's a sort of
all-you-can-eat pass where as a viewer I
can discover other comedians too so
anyways I think that there's a business
potentially for a mid-level Netflix for
comedians where you aggregate them what
do you think great I'm looking up
information so I can my brains rolling
and I'm gonna let me let me tell you
what I think so
first of all kwibi I imagine
trying to do something that so kwibi is
that even how you say it yes
it's pretty stupid I mean look I think
with kwibi
it actually can be great because the
people who are running it are like super
smart but it does not look like a good
bet now but it still might be anyway
they're trying to do something like that
second I think that that is a great idea
and I think the way that I would find
out how to do it is I would look up
quelle au q e ll Oh have you heard of
Cuomo I've never heard of it okay well o
is is it's a it's I think it was started
way before its time it's an app on Apple
TV and all they have is live concerts
and so it was started in 2010 and it's
available and it's like a it's a app for
your phone but I think it's best on
Apple TV and you could download it and
you pay ten thousand or is it maybe ten
dollars a month and sometimes does about
Elizabeth I think it's ten dollars a
month and you just get access to a
library of live concerts have you ever
wanted to do that or is that just me I
kind of do this on YouTube but YouTube
like has enough free like I listened to
a bunch of like Red Rocks concerts right
because there's a concert venue Club Red
Rocks which is awesome and like anytime
I'd musician goes there they film it in
like epic with epic cameras and sound
and they're just like available on
YouTube for free but this is cool I like
this it's awesome and it's it's better
than YouTube but YouTube is great and
the reason it's better is because like
if you buy like a concert DVD the camera
works a little bit better and the sound
is a lot better and I love live music
and so I am a big fan of this and they
have 70,000 paying subscribers they were
recently acquired by stingray
communications which is a publicly
traded company in Canada it's a cable
company so if I were you Sean and I
wanted to launch this or if I was a
listener I wanted to launch this I would
look up stingray communication and I
would go and read the the filing for
that company and I would figure out
exactly what quello does that's what I
would do and I would learn about how
they did it because it's a relatively
niche thing they only have 70,000
subscribers it's not huge and they've
been at it for ten years so it's not a
big number and I think it is incredibly
viable business and I think it's great
another thing another thing that I would
do is I would
look up Discovery Channel and then
National Geographic are you familiar
familiar with National Geographic or
obviously right okay National Geographic
is still a huge company and Disney
recently bought into it at a billion
dollar valuation it may still make they
still make hundreds of thousands or
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
from their magazine subscription is that
crazy then and so I would put date but
here National Geographic was a
non-profit and and so the good thing
about nonprofits is you can go to see
all the numbers and so what I would go
and look at I would look at Discovery
and I would look at National Geographic
and I was looking at koala and I would
see what they are doing because those
are relatively niche subscription
companies that crush so long story short
great idea
[Music]